i want to show you something that to me
is quite bizarre it's a tweet sent by
the mayor of miami florida
francis suarez saying that he wants to
take his next paycheck 100
in
bitcoin but wait scroll down and look at
the replies and there's this guy eric
adams saying that he wants to take his
next three paychecks in bitcoin oh and
by the way if you don't recognize this
guy it's because he was just elected as
the mayor of new york city
these are major politicians here and
they are very publicly promoting
cryptocurrencies
i feel like i can't go 10 minutes on the
internet without running into some
bitcoin this ethereum that or hearing
about some young dude becoming really
rich from some dog related meme money
i'm sure you've noticed this too if you
spend any time on the internet maybe
you've been avoiding it kind of like i
have because i don't know the vibes are
just kind of off thank you michael
it's weird it's really weird but there's
no avoiding this
2021 is the year that crypto went
full-blown mainstream since then we've
seen the price of bitcoin because of
right now i've made an extra 200 el
salvador became the first country in the
world on tuesday to make bitcoin legal
tender
bitcoin the whole thing is a joke even
the flintstones knew better than creep
though are you making any sense dogecoin
is the people's crypto this became a
dogecoin millionaire big story this
morning staples center getting a name
change yeah it is soon going to be known
as crypto.com
in cryptocurrency scams non-fungible
tokens they're taking over the art world
your work sold for 69 million dollars so
oh so it's a hustle
this movement started as a small
ideological project before eventually
attracting hordes of scams and gamblers
and now it's been embraced by wall
street and silicon valley
the question we all need to be asking is
not how does the blockchain work and
what's the technology that underpins all
this what you need to be asking is is
this takeover a good thing because
that's a really complicated question
hold on yes it is a great thing
okay
actually this is not good this is very
bad it's bad wait hold on a second i
don't do these types of videos where i
do like this sort of like debate myself
thing that's not what i do why are we
doing this well you do now
okay i'll let you two work this out and
debate the pros and cons of crypto but i
just want to say one last thing here
which is that this space is really hard
to navigate for anyone looking for good
information
most of the commentary around crypto
comes from people who have a direct
financial stake in getting more people
to buy their coin of choice there's a
lot of motivated reasoning that can
happen when your money is on the line so
with that i'm just gonna sit back
and enjoy the show
okay wait everyone pause just for a
second because i need to thank today's
sponsor because that's literally my job
and that's how i pay my bills so i'm
going to do that now and then we can get
back to it
the sponsor of today's video is better
help here's the fact of the matter
finding a therapist is really hard i
went through the process for several
years trying to find a good therapist by
calling doctor's offices and sitting in
waiting rooms and trying to see if they
lined up with my insurance betterhelp is
a platform that attempts to make this a
much easier smoother process what you do
is you go on you fill out your
information and they match you with a
licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating with
somebody within 48 hours
it is not a crisis line or a self-help
thing it is professional therapy that is
done on the internet
there's a broad range of expertises
there's a huge network of therapists so
that you can choose from people who
might not be available to you in your
city but are on this network and are
just in a different place and they make
it easy to change therapists if needed
it takes a moment to find a good
therapist sometimes and they make it
easy to change all of this is to say
that i'm a major fan of therapy
generally i think that therapy is way
too stigmatized and not accessible
enough in our society and it should be
it has changed my life and i think that
everyone should try to get therapy
better help is a platform that is trying
to make it more affordable than the
traditional slog of going and trying to
find a therapist
so if you want to try this out you can
get 10 off your first month if you go to
the link in my description it's
betterhelp.com johnny harris you get 10
off you can try it out see if it works
for you thank you betterhelp for
sponsoring this video now let's get back
to our debate go ahead guys okay let's
start out with the most obvious just
waste here which is all of the wasted
energy look at this chart this chart is
the amount of electricity it takes to
run the bitcoin network just bitcoin not
any other cryptocurrency
right now it's almost on par with the
electricity consumption of argentina
a whole country
why does it take so much energy to
create internet money well let's also
begin my question it's because the
security of bitcoin and ethereum depend
on thousands of computers
racing to randomly guess a 64-digit
number first day and night forever
and when the price of like bitcoin goes
up more computers jump on board which is
more electricity which is more climate
change and they work so hard that they
wear themselves out and just die after a
few years becoming a pile of useless
e-waste
tons of energy tons of waste why are we
doing this okay hold on hold on you've
been talking for long enough let me
chime in here
yes these computers use a lot of
electricity but not all of that
electricity is produced by burning
fossil fuels you'll notice that more and
more our electricity is clean it comes
from like solar panels and wind turbines
there's even this recent survey where
they ran around and asked where do you
get your electricity from and for the
crypto miners that responded 40 of their
energy comes from renewables crypto
mining is also well suited for grabbing
energy that might otherwise be wasted
there's this one oil facility in utah
where they have to burn a bunch of
natural gas because it's like a
byproduct from their oil extraction so
instead of just burning this into the
atmosphere they put a crypto mine in a
shipping container to use that natural
gas as electricity to run their
computers stuff like this is brilliant
and it's happening all over the place
there's also wind energy from these big
wind turbines oftentimes the wind is
blowing and making electricity at times
when humans don't really need it like in
the middle of the night so these crypto
computers that are mining cryptocurrency
never need to sleep and so they can ramp
up in the night and use this electricity
that would have otherwise just gone to
waste
and besides why are we singling out
crypto for using energy everything uses
energy the question is whether or not
the product merits that use which it
does and let me explain why wait no no
no no you're not going to explain why
because that's the whole point you just
said it you're talking about internet
money that's built off of electricity
and fancy math
i hate math the product is useless it's
actually worse than useless it's
actually harmful every week some new
crypto company gets hacked or runs some
scam or claims that their scam was a
hack there's no consumer protection it's
the wild west and there's a lot of
predatory behavior
the most recent example is this squid
game cryptocurrency investors crying
scam over cryptocurrency inspired by the
hit netflix show squid game someone
decided to make a cryptocurrency called
squid
they posted this beautiful paper
outlining that it was like a play to
earn online game it was going to be
released next month they got all the
hype going
the price shot up like this and as soon
as it got right here the creator cashed
out
and disappeared with over three million
dollars oh
it went to zero this happens all the
time well why are people buying it
people should wouldn't be buying it if
it wasn't on something people are
willing to buy whatever if there's
enough hype why are you buying it
because it's supreme and because of guys
like this a 33 year old california dude
who put his entire savings into dogecoin
and now he says he's a millionaire
everyone wants to be this guy they want
to be the next version of this dude this
is classic casino psychology the winners
are nice and loud telling everyone how
lucky they were and the losers quietly
retreat into their shame
it all creates this false impression
that everyone is getting hilariously
rich and you're not which
happens to literally be the name of this
new york times headline which is not
very helpful for quelling the fomo among
people who might invest their precious
money into fake internet
the money is there's nothing backing
this this is all human psychology which
i get it a lot of financial systems are
human psychology but when you invest in
a home or a business stock you're
betting on something that has a track
record of being useful to people
with crypto you're investing in a belief
that a bigger group of followers is
coming behind you and that each of those
people will be betting on the same
belief it's not even a scheme per se
it's
i have to go make a call
those guys at the top need us to buy or
they lose
you may have noticed that recently on
your paypal app or your cash app
you can now buy crypto
well it turns out that the ceos of those
companies these guys are both personally
invested in bitcoin
they're up here at the top of the
pyramid and so of course they're gonna
make it easy for you to buy into because
they get rich if you buy in
but the upshot is yes it is possible to
make money with this
it's always been possible to get rich
with rising bubbles that transfer wealth
from the late adopters to the early ones
that doesn't mean it's a good investment
and it also definitely doesn't mean it's
good for the world dude you're totally
missing the point okay
yes it is true and you're right that in
these early days there's a lot of
nonsense and scams and garbage happening
but that's what happens when there's
innovation people jump in and try things
out they make mistakes people get
scammed but eventually the technology
matures that's where we're headed here
don't look at the random dude who's
getting rich instead you need to look
back at the first year of bitcoin back
in january 2008
let's talk about the speed with which we
are watching this market deteriorate
this could be the most serious recession
in decades the economy was in a free
fall
banks and regulators had massively
mismanaged our financial system
governments were bailing out these banks
because they were quote too big to fail
and out of nowhere someone writing under
a pen name satoshi nakamoto
proposed this idea of bitcoin which was
a peer-to-peer electronic cash system
something that wouldn't need governments
or banks the first block of code to
start off this decentralized record that
every bitcoin transaction would be built
upon in that first code you see a little
easter egg
a headline from the day's news
of governments bailing out banks
nakamoto wrote that quote the root
problem with conventional currency
is all the trust that is required to
make it work bitcoin would solve this
using the same ethic that had built the
internet
connecting strangers from around the
world
without the need of a middleman
so yes this is useful because detaching
money from these big institutions that
have screwed it up
is useful for a lot of things oh yeah
totally you mean like buying drugs well
yes but also a bunch of other things
that you probably can't imagine because
you live here in the united states
consider nigeria for a second
last year the government literally froze
the bank accounts of 20 people who were
protesting police brutality in the
country but some of them were able to
still receive donations through bitcoin
because the government couldn't freeze
that look at another example venezuela a
place where a stack of money is worth
nothing because of hyperinflation purse
is made entirely of the bills of the
venezuelan currency the bolivar is
inflation is so high that this money is
now completely worthless this wiped out
people's life savings all because of
trust in these big institutions these
are problems that don't happen with
bitcoin there's no government that can
freeze your account there's no
government that can print more money and
devalue your coins it's not controlled
by governments or a team of executives
it's controlled by the community
the fact of the matter is all money is
turning digital and let me guess you
probably trust your central bank and
your government because you live here in
the us
but according to the human rights
foundation more than half the world's
population lives under an authoritarian
regime i get it i get it removing banks
and governments as the middleman has
some major upside
but who's going to protect the nigerians
and venezuelans from bitcoin scammers
and hackers
i mean just look at this list this is a
list of all of the cryptocurrency
exchanges that have been hacked it's a
really long list imagine if you're just
a normal consumer who isn't like a tech
person like if you don't have at least
some institutional buffer you're way
more vulnerable but the blockchain it's
so secure it's public record it's
verified through all this fancy
technology yeah the blockchain is the
blockchain is a fantastic really cool
thing but people aren't interacting with
the blockchain directly you still need
all of these services to buy and sell
your crypto it's these third-party
companies that turn into another
middleman vulnerable of being hacked and
they are all the time but let's just say
that your crypto assets are totally safe
they never get hacked you're still
subject to insane levels of volatility i
mean look at bitcoin's graph it's
swinging all of the time it swings by 30
percent or more
which is great if you're like a risk
tolerant guy with a ton of money to play
with on the internet this is a really
fun thing to do but what if you're
somebody who actually needs your
currency to stay stable so that you can
know its value so that you can go buy i
don't know groceries
so how do you control these hyper
volatile assets so that they stay
predictable
well
maybe some sort of authority middleman
and now we're right back into the messy
world of trust and middlemen government
control this is happening right now in
el salvador el salvador became the first
country in the world on tuesday to make
bitcoin legal
what does this mean for bitcoin what
does this mean for el salvador earlier
this year the president of el salvador
announced that bitcoin would become like
an official currency like a legal form
of money and that every business in the
country would have to accept it it will
run as another option alongside the
current currency us dollar but guess
what all of the infrastructure to
actually use bitcoin to buy things the
app where you can actually exchange and
buy bitcoin the atms to withdraw the
cash it's controlled by the national
government
it's like crypto is fantastic in theory
and for a select few people who have
disposable income to play around with
but it rarely happens in practice
without the same old dynamics of a
middleman coming in to make sure it
works for the masses oh gosh you're
focusing so much on how it works now i
mean if you were to apply that logic
like go back to the internet 1.0
[Applause]
wake up and smell the 90s
you have an internet browser in the
1990s we have the birth of a website it
is a thing that you log on to the
internet you read things you click links
and that's it it is a read only
experience people could have thought
like oh that's the internet like this is
what we do we go read things this is
boring it's just a digital encyclopedia
that's connected to other people's
computers i don't need a history lesson
where are you going with this just hear
me out for a second yeah hear him out
come on wait a minute you're still here
yeah i'm still here i've been here the
whole time trying to make up my mind as
you two argue go ahead okay okay so that
was the internet in the 90s but then we
got web 2.
[Music]
in the 2000s you start to see web pages
go from static to dynamic users can now
generate their own content from blogs to
uploading to myspace and then facebook
and youtube they're now participating in
the internet they're upvoting comments
that's where we are now we're in a part
of the internet where you're actually
participating we are creating the
internet together
but in doing so
we created these centralized digital
kingdoms
owned by giant tech companies who in
exchange for us being able to
participate in this cool new internet
they take our data they show us ads and
they make billions and billions and
billions of dollars
sometimes they share a little bit of
those billions of dollars with the
creators but most of us are doing free
work for these big tech companies so
that we can participate and make content
for their interactive web pages
there's a better way web three
this is what we're moving into it'll
allow us to move money make purchases
connect with people without the
permission of mark zuckerberg or jp
morgan or the government of the united
states they're not a part of this
equation at all it is a vision for an
entirely new type of internet do you
hear yourself you sound like some like
authoritarian politician peddling some
utopian vision for the future let's get
back to facts wait no this is actually
happening this isn't some nebulous
vision for the future we get it bitcoin
was a currency that is inherently
limited but ethereum is a new technology
that uses the same concept of getting
rid of middlemen but instead of just
allowing us to do the currency thing it
allows you to do tons of things that we
used to need institutions for it's
something called a token oh gosh here we
go again with tokens tokens tokens
tokens tokens let me guess are going to
save the world they're going to change
everything everything is solved by
tokens on the blockchain all i see
tokens being used for is selling digital
art for millions of dollars to
speculators who want attention on the
internet yes making digital things
scarce on the internet is one of the
first major applications for this but
this is just the beginning you gotta
think ahead man think about it borrowing
money signing contracts investing
there's so many things that we do where
there are huge middlemen in the center
who are making tons of money off of
ensuring that the transaction goes
properly i mean just imagine an internet
that is owned and governed by the users
instead of logging on to each of these
platforms with your separate username
and giving over all of your data you log
on to one unique wallet that holds all
of your personal information all of your
crypto assets that are protected by this
very sophisticated cryptography your
data isn't owned and stored by these
giant tech companies but instead it is
stored on encrypted ledgers and you get
to decide who you share it with and how
to value it i'm telling you i know it's
really early and all you're seeing is
like
millions of dollar cat gifts
but what this is doing is fueling a
creative boom among really bright
developers which in 10 years from now
will have totally transformed the
internet i hear you painting this
picture of some internet utopia where
everyone has a voice i would love a
world where users actually have
ownership over what happens online and
they can share decision making and
revenue
and while we're talking about blockchain
this cure-all technology that people
just throw around like it's gonna save
everything let us remember that in
reality blockchain is secured with
cryptography which is actually very
inefficient by design if you really want
decentralization
you need to have a network that is
redundant
and slow and hard to navigate without a
third party being your middleman you the
user have to trust in these companies to
run things smoothly so why do you need a
blockchain anymore when now you're
trusting a third-party company to do all
this work for you i think it's a much
more narrow tool than you think and a
lot of people are going to lose a lot of
money before they realize that that's
the case
okay let's all take a deep breath that
was
a lot
and as impassioned as this got
i promise you it's a hundred times more
intense
in twitter feeds around the internet
people feel very strongly on both sides
of this you'll probably be seen in the
comments here pretty soon i want to know
which of these people you agree with do
you agree with the optimistic view of
crypto or do you think that this is just
another obscure technology that will
have its day and be a bubble that
eventually bursts
for me i'm still learning i'm gonna
drink in as much information on this
topic as it develops because we're still
in the early stages and i actually don't
think it's healthy that we have to make
our minds up on topics that are still
really really theoretical to me it's a
much better idea to sit back and take in
the information as it comes and
eventually you'll start to develop your
own opinion
you should be compelled to do so by the
evidence by the data that speaks to you
not by angry bullies in twitter feeds
so
keep your mind open
but not so open that your brain falls
out be careful out there
[Music]
don't forget to buy dogecoin and buy um
ethereum